ABC's 3's company was one of the most
successful sitcoms on television Suzanne
Summers who played the voluptuous and
ditsy Chrissy snow thought a pay raise
was an order however her efforts ended
with her getting booted off the show The
Hollywood Reporter Revisited the story
of Summers firing in 2015 saying that
Summers was getting paid $330,000 per
episode while co-star John Ritter was
bringing home
$150,000 when Summers asked for more ABC
offered her a bump of $5,000 per episode
but the actress stood her ground and
demanded the same amount Ritter was
receiving after ABC refused Summer's
demand the actress missed the tapings
for season 5's thirdd and fourth
episodes and was soon fired before this
happened Summers manager and husband
Alan Hamill was allegedly warned earlier
that year ABC had bowed to pressure and
given raises to Penny Marshall and Cindy
Williams who at the time were the leads
of lever and Shirley Hamill said a
friend with connections at ABC called
and told him that ABC made an example of
Summers to end talk of any more big
paydays to Leading women